[Music]
hello welcome to opengl demo
episode 8 where we are working on
shaders and doing all kinds of cool
things with shaders
so next up we are going to get into some
projection
matrices and just projecting images
around on the screen
so that way you could take in theory any
effect
that you want and render it to
whatever set of triangles you want and
put it anywhere on the screen
as you can see here i got a little
algorithm going on a rotating plane
and this is essentially what you do and
you just apply different
algorithms all over the place wherever
you need them and just build them in
your shaders
so to do all of this we're just going to
go ahead and walk through the code i've
basically just added
a whole new shader setup which is right
here
and we are now using a vertices which
takes some
projection variables
and you can find that right here it
takes a projection matrix model matrix
and a v matrix
times them all together in this order
and here's how we color that frag
this is one of the algorithms from that
website the book of shaders
and i've just made a few changes to it i
added run
time so we do set that
and just made a little variation on the
noise
based on the run time so all these
randoms are different
and that's what gives it that back and
forth wishy-washy you see on this
square it's hard to kind of tell why
it's rotating but we can do some editing
here
and make it so it doesn't rotate so of
course there's the shader
and all that being set up and everything
being set
if you walk through that it should all
make sense
and of course also we have to make sure
the callbacks are up to date
so when the window size changes we want
to make sure we update that shader as
well
[Music]
and now let's go down to our while loop
you can see here we do
our whole set everything and then draw
strip
and this is where we're doing the rotate
we're using glm functions there's other
stuff you can do
but you can go look up these functions
on glm about
rotate translate scale and you can
set that however you want so for example
if we just turn this off
you'll see that it no longer rotates
it's just sitting there
and that's what that random variation
does i think it's pretty cool
reminds me of like an ocean so you could
potentially reuse this type of effect
for
water or something like that
to fully understand projection you're
going to have to do a lot of research
it's a pretty big topic on its own it's
basically
used to kind of map
out squares or areas
i'm butchering the explanation khan
academy has some great
courses on it it's used for shadow
mapping
and some other things in 3d i'm honestly
not an expert on it i've done some of
the courses but
i still have a lot to learn too i'm
mostly just
applying it here and
giving a very brief overview of it the
view matrix we're not actually using yet
but this is what we will well i say
we're not using it here it's just
a plain old
identity matrix so it's not actually
doing anything when you multiply it by
an identity matrix
it doesn't change the result
so we're not actually using it yet but i
put it in here as
preparation because this is what we will
change
when we start moving around and rotating
our camera
so our camera is just in place right now
just looking down the z axis so it's
looking down the negative z
because of course we are in the right
handed coordinate system
and to make that plane smaller i did set
the projection and then just translated
it
backwards or down the mop negative z
so field of view is 45
but we can play around with this if we
want
now i do have this also in the callback
too and it makes it look further away
so that's generally how you scope in if
you want to like zoom way
and you just make this really tiny
like 12 will look pretty zoomed in there
we go
so your field of view kind of does
determine how far it looks like you are
away from things
i think 45 is what they say
approximately humans see
like so i tend to start with that but a
lot of
fps games and stuff will allow you to
adjust this
other changes that were made since the
last video
i turned the shaders into unique
pointers and they're now global
i also made these uh
camera variables global field of view
near and far that way we can use it in
the callbacks
without having to pass it around
i also changed the naming scheme of our
gsl
source code to start out with frag or
vert eventually we'll have gm for
geometry and we'll get into some other
ones eventually but i think this naming
scheme is going to be a little better
than what we were using before
i also improved the query shader
function so that it displays results a
little better
for our active inputs on our shaders
which is great for our debugging
i updated the cursor so that it is no
longer just a circle as you may have
noticed
it is now a eighth of a circle
so that there is not the mouse from
windows that is one we're drawing with
the shader
i kind of like to look at this it's a
pretty simple algorithm
i'll step through real quick here
so basically all we need to take in is
the mouse position
to this fragment and of course as far as
work goes we're just using the 2d
flat one
so as we go into our main well we have a
radius declared
i could make this uniform too if we
wanted to adjust it on the fly
it's actually a great idea i'm going to
do that real quick
this does mean we need to set it all
completely in our c plus code
and we're also going to stick with our
naming scheme for these uniforms
with u radius
and then once we make our shader we want
to be sure to at least set that
once to make sure it is ready to go so
we'll use our shader after we declare it
here
and then just say cursor shader
set float
your radius and 13. so that way we could
change this on the fly like we could
hold this as a variable and change it
with a hotkey or
whatever we wanted to do with it so this
would give us a little more control for
example
and just make sure this works
well of course we got to update the
names in the shaders everywhere it's
used
okay forgot to do that okay now let's
run it
and there we go it's a little bit larger
than before
okay so all this does is it goes through
and it checks what quadrant
the pixel is compared to the mouse so
everything
at the top left top right and bottom
left
is discarded based on these first two if
x is negative
well first we get the direction from the
frag coordinate like so just subtract
the mouse position
if the x is negative we're on the left
side so we don't want that
or if y is positive we're on the top
side we don't want that we're looking at
bottom right
and that gets rid of the four quadrants
and this or
gets rid of uh
half of the bottom right quadrant if x
is less than what the negative y is
because y is definitely negative
then we're at the more right side
or the more right quarter of that
quadrant
and we discard that as well and that's
how we get the final eighth
that's this cuts it from the fourth to
the eighth so we got this it would just
be the quarter
all right and then we just color based
on that distance
and just make a small circle just like
before
when we're just using colors black and
white we could
use whatever colors we want or take
uniforms for colors so we could have all
kinds of settings for our mouse
based on this cursor however many
uniforms we wanted to bring in
or uh you know put up here and mess with
so pretty cool way you can just get your
own hardware rendered mouse and
customize it
and that is all the changes i believe
[Music]
okay well that's it for this episode
thank you all so much for watching
special shout out to my patrons for
making this episode possible
let me know if you have any questions
about these shaders of course check out
the github repo
it's got all this code i'll push it up
and i'll tag
video eight for this exact code all
right i'll see you in the next one matt
from codetek tutorials over now
[Music]
[Music]
you